he's not bluffing Vladimir Putin making
a chilling threat of nuclear war and
trying to upstage President Biden's big
speech to the United Nations the Russian
leader calling up hundreds of thousands
of reservists to fight Ukraine following
Frontline setbacks in the war there
while claiming he is not bluffing when
it comes to his nuclear threats here's
Biden hours later
Putin has made over nuclear threats
against Europe
and a reckless disregard
for the responsibilities of the
non-proliferation regime this war
is about extinguishing Ukraine's right
to exist as a state plain and simple
and Ukraine's right to exist as a people
whoever you are
wherever you live whatever you believe
that should not that should make your
blood run cold Biden did get to speak
about his favorite topic
I've signed a historic piece of
legislation here in the United States
that includes the biggest most important
climate commitment we have ever made in
the history of our country this is a
global game changer
and none too soon we don't have much
time
we all know we're already living in a
climate crisis
no one seems to doubt it after this past
year
you know Greg right now what you've got
is uh months and months of a war that
should have been ended supposedly within
a few weeks and now Vladimir Putin's
back is against the wall and he's got
his finger he's alleging and threatening
against the uh on a nuclear button and
he's threatening all of us and he does
have a nuclear Arsenal I find it
interesting that uh in this you saw
Biden talking about I wonder is 57 60
billion dollars in arms sent to Ukraine
does that help or hurt the climate
crisis just putting it out there I mean
it kind of seems like you can't say both
things you can't tell us we're in a
crisis and then keep a war going on with
billions and billions of our dollars
with you know missiles and bombs and
trucks I think these reservists thing I
don't think Putin planned on this it's a
credit to the Ukrainian fighting force
and our billions of dollars but this is
a I think this is a good sign for
Ukraine because I don't think millions
of Russians are going to be happy that
their fathers and their brothers and
their sons who were reservists who may
have retired are being called back in to
fight in the Ukraine that's the other
thing I don't think it's comforting to
know that your Russian soldiers may not
be coming back anytime soon I mean
you're like they're not even letting the
ones that are there come back unless
they're dead so this has got to I mean
this from a morale perspective and this
is really an information War at this
point it's a war of persuasion between
two sides and I think that this is like
a blow to Russia to how do they explain
this uh the morale is going to go
downhill well and you know Dana the
truth is that with three hundred
thousand I I think is the estimate of
reserves that they're calling out and
then you've got people moving out of
Russia at a record number
this was supposed to be easy and now
what we've got is he seems like a madman
so it's supposed to be I think that
either he had bad intelligence or he
just assumed it would be easy or he
thought the military was going to be his
military would be a lot more effective
than they were and that the ukrainians
were going to fold so none of that
happened and then in the last two weeks
Putin has had a pretty rough time of it
because both the Chinese leader and the
Indian leader had meetings last week
with him where they said yeah we're not
for this and you need to figure out a
way to wind this down then he has
pressure from inside his own government
um the people that are saying like how
could you let this happen you're
embarrassing us on the world stage you
have to do something so he might say
something like using a tactical nuclear
weapon or Worse could be something the
high Mars which are the are the the
weapons that we're been providing
they're extremely effective and they
can't deal with that especially if
they're trying to buy weapons from North
Korea in order to fight back however I
maintained that Putin's strongest weapon
that he will use against the West he's
already deploying which is to shut off
energy
and so the ukrainians can do very very
well that because the the West continues
to hamstring itself in its energy
production they are going to be in a
world of hurt this winter and we this is
a warning for the United States we have
to have a better policy so we never get
into this position well with this with
this Administration I don't know that
we're going to have a better policy as
it relates to energy and and the truth
is I mean this guy thinks he can
threaten us and that we're afraid of him
and the high Mars uh weapons that that
Dana refers to when he talks about you
you threaten our territorial Integrity
you're going to get it so energy
security is something we're learning a
lot more about in the Europeans are
learning a lot more about I don't blame
us fully for their challenges we should
be producing more here but the Europeans
are going to have to adopt the different
energy posture going forward two who's
losing
um seven eight months ago this
conversation there was a lot of
consternation in our conversation about
what the administration should be doing
or not be doing there were those that
thought that the president was moving
too slowly I gave him the benefit of the
doubt it turns out they were far more
right than wrong uh they're 70 80 70 to
80 000 Russians have been killed they
cannot call they cannot impose a draft
to bring more soldiers into this because
as Greg so aptly said people don't want
to do this I think what Dana said is
probably the most important thing is we
confront this question right here which
is how the in how India and China are
are perceiving uh Putin at this point
they have been allies of his India has
been on the sidelines which you can
construe as being an ally in this in
this effort in China and China's leader
and Russia's leader got got together
seven months ago and said there was a
limitless nature to their relationship
and then China's leaders said no I might
need to back that up a little bit this
is not going as we thought the question
now becomes what happens what is the
what is the negotiated
out to this I can't imagine zelinski is
going to give up any land you shouldn't
uh and it's hard to to stomach to Greg's
Point how does Putin look at people in
the face there in Russia and say we did
all of this we we lost all of these
troops we we were exposed to not have
the military people thought we had but
we're going to back up now we're at a
hard point now and it will take the
blinkins and the others of the world and
our and our uh diplomacy Corps to help
figure out how we get out of this
Jesse well I wouldn't rely on the
blinkins to get us out of it he's our
secretary I understand but he's not
really if you think about it what has he
done where has he been Ken is right uh
they'll just freeze the Italians and the
Germans if they squeeze the pipeline
this winter I mean if they have to
mobilize more Russians I mean what are
they going to hand them a 20 year old
rifle and say aim and squeeze I'm gonna
give him some crummy boots wait till the
winner comes around it's they're going
to be cannon fodder this is the worst
military performance I've ever seen and
I've been a student of military history
but it's not so much all the weapons
that we loaded up to the Ukraine's which
obviously made a crucial difference no
one expected the military tactics to be
this terrible from the Russians the
training's awful their equipment is old
and has cobwebs in it and they can't
even communicate so it's been a disaster
it's hard to fight Insurgency look at
the American colonists look at the
Vietcong look at the Afghans when you're
fighting for your own Survival in your
own backyard and you do have some
weapons you can put a hurting on these
Invaders but if I were Putin I'd say
whatever I wanted to say you could just
lie what are they going to do impeach
you what are you worried about your next
election come on the guy's a dictator
and all of his guys keep having these
accidents every day you open the paper
and another one of Putin's guy slips on
a banana peel gets pushed off of a yacht
I mean these guys must be really clumsy
or they're being assassinated I feel
judged I feel the same way about the U.N
we are being invaded we are being
invaded we can't move in our city
because the U.N is year it was great
when there was covet and there was no
U.N yeah I know and now
they're back they're using all our
escort services yeah
and paying foreign
companies are hell-bent on cramming
their left-wing agenda down your throat
whether you like it or not hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else